(bright music)
- [Ellen] My job is
actually 24 hours a day
to take care of my hands.
- [Susan] I'm definitely
very cautious with my hands.
I'm more careful. I'm more
delicate with my movements.
- [Nico] I get manicures
fairly frequently.
I don't do them myself.
- My name is Ellen Surat.
- Susan Schell
- Tom Nico and I am...
- A hand model.
- [Susan] I got noticed as a
hand model after I was featured
in a jewelry shoot for a
magazine at the jewelry
company I was working at.
- [Tom] One day I was
on a commercial shooting
in Central Park and they picked
me to do all the hand shots
because the hand model never showed up.
Probably most of us fall
into it by accident.
- [Ellen] I'm always in
these upside down positions
and having to have the
director on top of me
or underneath me.
- [Sarah] You're being asked
to do the most natural things
in the most unnatural ways.
- [Tom] Sometimes I am in weird positions.
- [Sarah] For my oddest
hand shoot, I had to pretend
to chop a live human placenta.
- [Ellen] I had to do
this one thing where I had
to be on Howard Stern's kinda naked body.
(laughs)
- [Tom] He says to me, look,
we're going to try something different.
I want you to stick your
thumb in the girl's mouth.
I've been a hand model around 19 years.
It's been great.
I've been very lucky.
- [Ellen] I feel like, I'm
gonna do this 'til I'm 90.
(laughs)
My hands are going to look
great and I love doing it
(bell dings)
and you always need a hand
that looks really good.